I have something just really important
for you today but it also happens to be
entertaining and I think most of you are
going to enjoy this there's a company
called Salesforce we've used this
company off and on to manage our ad
sales process it's a CRM a customer
relationship management tool and doesn't
even really matter what that is but
their CEO is a guy named Marc Benioff
and he's a smart guy he has some really
progressive ideas at least in the
context of someone who runs a huge
corporation and happens to be a multi
billionaire reportedly worth more than
6.4 billion dollars about two-thirds of
that in Salesforce company stock
he has a narrative about capitalism
about the role of big business that is
pretty different from what a lot of
other big corporate CEOs have and he's
been talking for a while now about a new
capitalism a more social capitalism
capitalism without going off the rails
so to speak a capitalism that accounts
for the well-being not just of the
shareholders as is often the case but
also of stakeholders which include all
employees customers the environment
capitalism for social change rather than
capitalism for preventing social change
and he was interviewed on CNBC by the
usual suspects including this guy named
Jim Cramer who's known in the investment
world and he turned their world visibly
upside down and they didn't know what to
do with him so we're gonna look at some
clips this is a 12-minute interview in
total which you can find online I'm
gonna play a few clips for you and
throughout this you might notice there
will be times where the camera is a wide
shot and you'll notice Jim Cramer just
looking exasperated with Marc Benioff
who's not going to be bullied by the
sort of vulture capitalist mentality
into saying anything other than what
Marc Benioff believes and he happens to
believe many of the right things and
you'll see Jim Cramer go in on him about
are we really gonna break up big tech
which Elizabeth Warren has been
suggesting and Marc Benioff says yeah
yeah we should last night I heard
capitalism under attack as I never heard
it before it
and it made me think that if it's dead
there are two visions there's your
vision which is to resurrect it make
business the greatest prat platform
social changed and there's another
vision which is that the government has
to step in because the billionaires are
screwed up so badly tell us how to get
that not blow they're probably right
actually but we do we need a new
capitalism we need a capitalism that's
more fair more equitable more
sustainable capitalism capitalism that
values not just all shareholders but
also all stakeholders and if we can put
those things together I think it can be
a new capitalism to be very exciting for
everybody I do worry mark that in the in
the vacuum in the vacuum of what you're
talking about what I heard last night
about big tech having to be broken up
simply cuz it's got tremendous power
not even that the powers being used
unwisely but it where are you when it
comes down to breaking up Facebook
breaking up amazon breaking up alphabet
aren't just create American companies to
hire a lot of people well you know how I
feel Jim Facebook is the new cigarettes
it's addictive how bad change
Jim they're after your kids that's not
fair at all change more look at the
political ads that are going on there's
you know not a commitment to trust and
truth and now they're commingling the
data of all of their acquisitions
Facebook probably should be broken up
because they're using these assets in a
way to further manipulate even more
people I think that there needs to be
change it hasn't happened fast enough
absolutely correct he's a huge
beneficiary of the system that we have
but he's saying plain and simple that
the system still has to be changed and
Cramer pushes back because he just
doesn't I mean he doesn't like it
he can't believe that a
multi-billionaire huge corporate CEO is
saying this stuff and Marc Benioff here
to the disbelief of the people on the
panel explaining that Salesforce has
returned great value to investors
investors in Salesforce have done really
well financially but that they're also
providing a return to stakeholders and
focusing on the environment and more
Marc you've been talking for some time
now about and that's the new capitalism
Jim
which is that look we have to actually
value all stakeholders we look at all
she lives sure but the others are
important and we've had a great
shareholder return that Salesforce I
heard you earlier mention it thirty five
hundred percent since I was first year
right there right there
in 2004 if you bought our stock well
that's a thirty five hundred percent
return but I had a great stakeholder
return to during that same period we've
given over three hundred million dollars
for grants four million hours of
volunteerism forty thousand nonprofits
and NGOs for free running on our service
and we're a NetZero company be fully
renewable by 2025 that's our stakeholder
return which to a stakeholder report so
we have a shareholder return and a
shareholder report with a stakeholder
return a stakeholder report and I think
that's something the SEC can do by the
way they could put you know I mentioned
that in my op-ed what a concept right I
mean blowing their minds you can see
that these people they're looking at
each other they're smirking they're
rolling their eyes they can't believe
that a company that makes money also
treats the planet in a more responsible
way and it treats stakeholders is an
important part of the considerations
that are made when you make business
decisions now disclaimer time I'm not
saying Marc Benioff is perfect
I'm not saying Salesforce is the perfect
company and there are no negative
externalities to what Salesforce does
there well maybe but the way in which
these simple socially democratic ideas
are coming from a multi-billionaire CEO
and triggering Jim Cramer is just
delightful watch Cramer in this next
clip if you're watching if you're just
listening I encourage you to find the
full interview online but while David
Faber takes a turn asking some questions
of Marc Benioff Jim Cramer looks
perplexed as Marc Benioff explains hey
there are actually CEOs all over the
world being more thoughtful about how we
run our businesses what are the metrics
how do you measure this given it is
growing and importance we hear about it
all the time now from real money not
just sort of a you know a broad sense
that there's interest in it but people
actually who want to put dollars behind
it
well I my peers certainly do when I talk
to the largest CEOs
the world yesterday I was in Munich
Germany with one of the largest company
in Germany with their CEO they have a
major programme into place just as we do
just as many others do I was in London
on Monday I see the same thing
throughout Europe it's probably
happening faster there the United
Nations sustainable development goals
are the 17 core initiatives that are
laid out by the UN of how we're trying
to improve the state of the world and
company should have to report how
they're doing against those goals that
that just makes complete sense to me if
we're not all into improving the state
of the world then what are we all into
did you believe the Business Roundtable
when they change their statements or do
you think as some do that it was really
more of just kind of talk to get on the
right side of the politics of it the
Business Roundtable has said now exactly
the same thing the purpose of the
corporation is to value stakeholders as
important as shareholders that the
traditional Milton Friedman concept that
it's only about the shareholder that the
CEOs only job is to maximize shareholder
return is dead Wow oversight regulation
working together Milton Friedman's
teachings are obsolete it's not only
about maximizing shareholder value
socialism no this is not socialism this
is social democracy it's social
capitalism Marc Benioff doesn't say big
corporations shouldn't exist Marc
Benioff doesn't say billionaires like
him shouldn't exist
he is saying that we can do capitalism
in a different way still make money but
consider all stakeholders consider the
environment this is CNBC mind you this
is a billionaire tech CEO and you'll see
the wide shot again show Jim Cramer who
is just laughing to himself he can't
believe this is happening on CNBC there
we need to value all stakeholders and
all shareholders now what I say
stakeholders what do I mean I mean our
employees our customers our partners you
know but I also mean like I'm in from
San Francisco we have a horrible
homeless problem there the homeless are
a stakeholder for me that's why I was
fighting for proposition C attacks on
ourself because we have to get though we
have to deal with the homeless situation
in San Francisco if as the largest
employer in San Francisco I'm not
focused on that if they aren't one of my
key stakeholders than what is now we got
a question I had because the TechCrunch
you said if your orientation is just
about making money you're not going to
hang out for very long as a CEO or a
founder of the company my question was
if you don't then what you your board
fires you your sales drop you know you
can't hire anybody what is the
consequence of running afoul of that
well you can see that in my industry
which is for CEOs who do not take this
approach they are really at risk and
they can be extremely vulnerable
especially during economic times that
become turbulent stunning right who
could have imagined you could be a
corporate CEO or big corporation and
care about other people then Benioff
brings up climate change which is just
like it's lost on these folks and you'll
see them all smirk at each other what am
I doing wrong I need to be thinking
about the public schools the homeless oh
and I also need to be thinking about not
just profit but planet I need to be
thinking about the planet what are my
emissions you know that is part of the
new world we're in that gets back to
David's question on what about the
sustainable development goals in the UN
that is the connectivity that's the map
we can lay it out then we can measure if
we can measure it we can have impact
that's art one that we all know that we
understand how to do that before Jim I
know has to finish but there's some
shareholders right now are listening to
you who probably like what are you
talking about you seem to be abandoning
what I would want which is just you
focus on improving the profitability of
this company you worry that you freak
some of these people out and what do
they say to you when they hear that if
they're not on board with your view this
is how to improve the profitability of a
company this is how to make a great
company this is how to have a company
that customers want to do business with
that attracts employees if it develops
partnerships that integrates local
communities that saves the planet this
is about having a great company and look
at our company look at our financial
returns since we went public right here
in 2004 look at how we rank against
everyone else over the last same 15 year
period I'm sure that you
see we're in the very top echelon and
I'll tell you how we did it we valued
stakeholders as much as shareholders
consider that you improve the company by
caring about the world in which the
company exists by caring about the
people who could be employees or
potential employees customers of the
company just people who exist on this
planet shocking right and half of what
makes this great is the content of what
Marc Benioff is saying the other half is
just how triggered Jim Cramer is and his
incredulous reactions to what is being
said really great stuff and you know I
mean listen as I say don't idolize
politicians don't idolize big corporate
CEOs he's still the CEO of a huge
corporation that I'm sure does things
that we would all disagree with but this
was just a delightful wake up call and
taking it right to the horse's mouth
check out the full interview online it's
only about 12 or 13 minutes let me know
what you think about it